it's like if Justin Bieber was also an
Olympic Athlete you know I suppose so
yeah I find that there are similarities
though one taught me the the what you
put in is what you get out sort of
mindset the work equals success or work
equal at least equals Improvement but
it's different in the creative arts you
can't you can't grind a song out no at
least at least from my experience
um trying to improve as a guitarist or
trying to improve as a vocalist to say
go on technical to go on
um to do theater right I like to do
things like that
um things where the Reps pay off yeah
like
where you sort of push push push for for
a period of time so that you can let it
sort of happen when it's supposed to
happen so that the the the second nature
thing right can happen like right when
you're when you're when you're racing at
your Peak you're not using your brain
yeah exactly so you can you can think
think think think so that you can not
think when you when you don't have to